there are so many resources now where
you could just go to puzzles
click on mate in one you can literally
filter
puzzles by made in one and you solve
50 of them do that for a week and
imagine how much better you're going to
become at recognizing these patterns
right
so a lot of the time that people i think
get confused
about about training right about about
what they need to do to get to the next
level the the answer is just to
solve right and the rest is just going
to come because i think the
misconception people think well i don't
know a key fact
or a key way of thinking that it's
preventing me from getting to the next
level that's why i'm wondering
often the reason isn't that you don't
know something it's that you
don't know how to apply it and you just
gotta give yourself more practice okay
[Music]
let's play one e4 in the next game we're
playing 480
and e4 e5 so there are many options
many options for aggressive and good
gambits
for beginners i'll talk about the
philosophy of that in
uh after the game one such gambit is the
danish gamut the danish gambit is where
you play d4
immediately striking in the center they
take the pawn normally they take the
pawn
and then queen takes d4 is the center
game it's a
not a very good opening but the danish
gambit is playing the move
c2 to c3 what is the zen of the danish
gambit most gambits
sacrifice one or more pawns the danish
gambit sacrifices two pawns in order to
get a lead in development a leading
development just means
you get more of your pieces out than
your opponent than your opponent
and gambits are our mentality right to
play a gambit you need to have a certain
mentality
where you are ready to sacrifice if
necessary upon if necessary more than
that
to to get a lead in development to play
with the initiative so
you have to be fond of aggressive play
now here black declines the gamba black
plays c5
decline gambit is when your opponent
refuses to take the pawn that you have
offered him so he plays the move c7 to
c5 that's not a bad move actually
but it's not a great move either the
reason it's not a great move is
partially because he blocks the bishop
from developing to c5
and he creates a weakness on d5 and i'll
define the term afterward but
essentially
in short empty chairs thanks for the
prime a weak square is a square
that cannot be defended by a pawn
okay that's a pretty simple definition
actually um and the d5 square
cannot be defended by any pawn because
the the e pawn is now on d4 and the c
pawn is on c5 it doesn't go backwards
now how can we develop with an eye
toward immediately
claiming this d5 square
uh we can take on d4 but let's put on
that gambit hat
we don't need to take on d4 we're ready
to sacrifice the pawn bingo
bishop c4 it's not the best move if he
plays well
you can respond to this well but it's
it's a very thematic move that sets up a
lot of attacking ideas
and again remember the gambit mentality
the gamut mentality means
that you don't necessarily care about
each individual pawn you are
focusing um much more on
dev peace development than on individual
pawns
so you guys might see well he's
threatening the e4 but maybe i should go
and i
detour queen e2 but i'm thinking about
this much differently
very simple just go knight f3 that's
that's how you normally develop
five buck from rogue force thank you so
much knight e4 how do we maximize our
development
and he's playing this very well by the
way like the way that i'm playing
black will be better if he plays like a
gm with full due respect to mezroel
i think he's not a gm castle see and
at the heart of aggressive play when you
hear that aggressive play gambit play
is actually a very sound command of the
fundamentals
and when i say fundamentals i mean
things like proper development proper
piece placement
and knowing when to put aside material
considerations
for more important things like rapid
development now black's best move here
would be d7 to d5
immediately hitting the bishop not an
easy move for some you know for a
beginner to find
um but so far he's impressed me with
this play
now i i do need to address the question
of cheating and stuff we will definitely
encounter some cheaters in the pool that
there's
no question about it the key and what i
always ask of you guys is a to give
everybody the benefit of the doubt
i'm not going to stand for any
accusations before we carefully
investigate the game
even if it's obvious um because
we owe that to people in case they
actually are underrated or play well
but let's keep things positive even if
we do face a tutor that's the sort of
important thing here
okay so um
what do we do now he's played a6 that's
sort of a a waste of a move
but we know that black does want to play
d5
right black wants to play d5 which would
open up the bishop
it would attack our bishop and would
control more of the center
and the move rookie one is incredibly
tempting i get it
but black can still play d5 in response
to rookie one
if i go rookie one imagine this black
plays d5
and he defends the knight in addition to
attacking the bishop
so the obvious follow-up is well let's
put a bishop on d5 but there is another
way to approach this
rather than putting a bishop on d5 you
can try to control this square and that
can be a lot more conducive
to your general plan think about it that
way
what comes to mind can we control d5 and
perhaps
add on to this bishop well the concept
of a battery
comes into play here we go queen to b3
pretty common move in danish gambit
related positions
stack up the bishop and the queen and
guess what we're already threatening
a devastating check on f7 you guys see
how that's more
effective right than playing bishop d5
which would send his knight back that's
all it would do
and i know i would never find that i
would push back on phrases like that
because
as corny as it sounds you know you have
to believe in your ability to find stuff
and
you know to apply logic and most of
these moves can be found
watching b5 so a6 my opponent
he intended b5 he doesn't properly put
this into context he allows bishop f7
check
yeah and i'll talk about the specific
moves afterward
okay so king is this is not check making
e7 is still possible
and these are positions where
particularly beginners really struggle
it's like you can sense that
very close to delivering checkmate you
need to reign things in
so after k7 let's wait for him to play
it
how should we approach this position
well there's a couple of things here oh
and i and i've mentioned this in the
five minute speedrun many times
observations
are at the heart of finding the vast
majority of
correct tactical solutions in most
positions so before we say
any moves let's make the proper
observations what
do i even mean by making observations
well there's a couple of things
there are tactical patterns right and by
tactical patterns i mean things like
king and the queen on the same diagonal
we see that here
those can alert you to the presence of
various tactics like bishop g5 as bishop
g5 good here
yes or no is it
does it win the queen it does
not win the queen because knight takes
g5 and that's not what we want
the other thing that you have to look
for is undefended pieces pieces
that are not protected by pawns or other
pieces
and i'll expand on that later but
undefended pieces
can be the sort of guide post for for
various things like forks and double
attacks so we see the knight on e4 is
clearly undefended the rook on eight is
clearly undefended
he has exposed that rook by playing b7
and b5
so while everybody wants to play rookie
one and that's a decent move
queen to d5 is what i would actually
play in
a game but because you know we're doing
the speed run
i'm gonna play rookie one that's a
simpler move it does
have one flaw and i will show that flaw
after the game if black finds this
kudos then we're still much better i'm
not giving up the advantage or anything
like that
um does anybody see what black should do
here
how yes c4 very nice c4 intercepts
the connection between the queen and the
bishop and that's the flaw let's see if
he finds it
and he does very nice he finds it
um okay so
don't worry everything is under i saw
this
and how do we go about thinking about
this position well
um you know
we messed up that's okay and i you know
we didn't literally mess up but how do
you think about the situation
well you need to make the most out of
the situation
because if you take the knight then he's
going to take the bishop
so if we're already losing the bishop if
we're already losing it what should we
do we should take the paul we should at
least
take something out with us that concept
by the way is
very often misunderstood right if you've
already come to terms with losing a
piece
then that's called a desperado sacrifice
you give the piece up for as much as you
can get in return
um now there's a lot going on here
there's actually a lot of complicated
tactics i didn't anticipate this in our
second game
but that's not a bad thing it's a good
thing there's a lot of cool stuff here
that i can unpack after the game
now we need to be very careful and i'll
explain that one
it's very complicated if we play if we
play queen takes c4 say oh this knight's
not going anywhere
black's going to play d5 so first we
need to take the knight
and again we need to be very careful
he's probably going to go king f7
particularly the move like i i know all
of you guys are seeing bishop g5 why
doesn't this win the queen the bottom
line is he's attacking my queen
see we get into a situation where both
queens are hanging
and that's a very complicated situation
now it's time for bishop g5 check
but after king to g6 we're not going to
take his queen yet
because our queen is also hanging
so why did we play bishop g5 in the
first place well it's good that we're
attacking his queen we'll be able to
move our queen
that's another situation where people
often make mistakes
well not queen b6 because he's defending
that square
okay so what do we do
so queen takes e4 yeah the
the best thing that you can do and he
still can go d5 an attacker queen it's
amazing how many resources black has
here but we're still winning there
the thing is um when two queens are
hanging that's one of the most
tactically charged situations in chess
what do you need to look for
what you need to look for is can i move
my queen away with check if you do so
the king moves and then we're free to
take his queen which is what happened
here
the problem is that black could have
gone d5 and attacked the queen at the
same time
and and that led to very cool tactical
complications
okay so when you're first starting chess
um and this is why i'm a little bit
nervous that we reached
position this i don't want to paint the
wrong image to beginners
of like oh you plunge into this super
complex
web of variations you need to focus on
the fundamentals
on adhering to opening principles and
stuff like that the variations are less
important they're fun
i'll show them but they're less
important so what should we do now how
do we get to this king
well maybe we can give a check on f7 no
we can't king takes f7
what other pieces can jump into the
attack well we look at our rook it's
near the king
we look at our knight can we go 95 well
then he would take the knight
we can go in that h4 maybe but rook g4
is the sort of most obvious move yeah
rook g4 that completes the rook lift
actually
and rook g4 is a check to the king the
king can't go back to f7
queen is covering that's where bishop is
covering f6 right
just methodically considering where the
king can go where it can't go
it got it's going to have five now a lot
of people here
and i think you know beginners have this
issue obviously not because
they're dumb but because it's natural to
have this issue the issue of
reflex moves right so king f5 you see
the rook is saying
so i know that a lot of you are thinking
rook g5 check i know it
but there is a mate that's faster
because remember you are in a king hunt
so when you're hunting the king it's
something you're hunting the king
you often have to sacrifice pieces using
them as
deco as lures to lure the king further
into your camp
so this g4 rook can be just such a lure
let's think logically after king takes
c4
from what square let's assume that the
king is on g4
from what square does the queen deliver
checkmate to the king where do we need
to put the queen
given that the king is on g4 well you
guys you guys are saying g5
is one that comes to mind how do we get
it there we can't play queen c5 that
drops the queen
just to the bishop that's also not the
fastest mate there wasn't made in two
i'll show that after the game
queen f7 check he can play knight e5 and
it's made in three
or actually no yeah yeah it is made in
three but now we g5 is checkmate
okay um good game
let's go over
and yeah so the danish gambit is
uh what we attempted to play we sort of
failed
um and he takes d4 yeah with two out of
two or awesome
he takes d4 c3 a little bit of history
now the danish gamut is a very old
opening it's uh
it's been around for a very long time if
you guys want to know exactly
when it was first mentioned i have a
book for that
give me a second some chess history
never hurt anybody
this move c3 i'll check
with the first mention later was played
for the first time in 1839 by
evans william davies evans in
london and his opponent played knight
knight f6 so his opponent declined
declined the danish gambit i'm not sure
why it's called the danish gambit
definitely had something to do with
denmark i'll investigate that later
um and our opponent played the move c5
which is a legitimate move it's it's
occurred in 49
games it's been played by some good
players
um but the accepted danish gambit is
obviously dtak c3 right
and now you guys might assume
that white is supposed to play knight
takes e3 but the cool thing about the
danish is you don't take this pawn back
you go bishop c4
and the first time that the danish
gambit was played in this version
the first time according to my records
that this position occurred
was 1863 by a guy named hans
linden who was apparently a master
and he was apparently the first person
to have this on the board in 1863
and the city of copenhagen played a club
match against the city of uppsala in
sweden in 1875 that may be where it got
its name
uh hans niman's great great grandfather
yes
um in any case that may be where it gets
sustained funny thing is copenhagen
lost that game anyways what is the idea
of the danish gambit
well just look at it with your eyes you
have both of your bishops developed and
they're both
aimed in the vicinity of the king so
even without analyzing a single
variation you can already kind of
understand
why this gamut exists and why it can be
dangerous right
uh hopefully that makes sense we won't
analyze it right now i'm sure that we'll
get a chance to play it
and then we'll kind of analyze it
properly so c5 is what my opponent
played
now bishop c4 so weak squares
i as i've defined them are squares that
cannot be defended
by pawns but you have to be very careful
about this definition
very careful about this definition
because by that token
right like well okay daniel said that
weak squares are squares that are not
defended not possible to defend but not
possible to divide by that
it doesn't mean like for example uh
b uh a4 is a4 a week square by our
definition no because white
can play the move b3 even though what
hasn't yet does that make sense
now the thing is it's called the
classical era of modern chess
not all weak squares are important
so by our definition d6
is also a weak square but
is it likely that white is going to get
a knight onto d6 anytime soon
i mean white will have to go here and
here and black's bishop defends that
square
i would say it's pretty unlikely that
that's going to happen anytime soon
the d5 square is very important because
we are literally controlling it
immediately with our bishop
so you've got to be very very uh
sort of discerning in how you approach
the question of weak squares
a square could be weak but that could be
just about as important as
you know what grade you got on ap
cal um not important
you know or it could be as important as
um
you know what grady got on ap english
very important
right so you have to be discerning when
it comes to weak stories i'll talk more
about this later thank you slower for
gifting discodemail
okay so knight f6 and now the move
knight f3 right
uh getting the night out and uh putting
the emphasis on development
knight takes c4 and castle this is what
i would call the gambit mentality
right this ability to constantly
prioritize development
over winning pawns back if i were to
play how i would actually play against
another grandmaster i would play c takes
d4 i would um
you know i i would take the pawn back
and then i would go knight f3
and win the pawn back and i'd have a
slight advantage hey ruja
but that's not what i'm doing here um
so a lot of people here would say well
why can't you play queen e2
who can explain that to me why why is
queen
why doesn't this win the night i mean
this clearly pins the night why doesn't
it win the night
because black has the move d7 to d5 i
mentioned this during the game it's
better than queen e7
because this gets the bishop out it
attacks white's bishop
and it protects the knight it kills so
many things with one stone right
okay um so castles a6 is the first
mistake
instead black should have played d5 then
i would have given a check with the
bishop
and at that point i would have had no
choice but to recover at least
one of the pawns i've sacrificed but
black can very quickly get his pieces
out c takes d4
bishop e7 and then black castles black
will be up a pawn so it's still
double wedged but black is doing well
here right
so instead my opponent plays a6 which is
sort of a classic violation
of the opening principle which says that
you should control the center and
develop your pieces if you're not doing
either of those things
it better be for a very good reason and
preparing v5 is not a very good reason
so queen b3 is the move that we played
in response
controlling the d5 square building a
battery and attacking f7
does this the logic behind this move
make sense now a lot of you guys
suggested putting the bishop on d5
and the problem with that move is that
black would have played knight f6
attacking the bishop and here's the
interesting thing
some of you guys may be looking at this
knight and saying well this knight is
annoying i want to get rid of this
knight i'm looking at this knight
i'm saying i love the fact that that
knight is on e4
but wait a second isn't this knight in
the center isn't it a bad thing for us
when our opponent has his pieces in the
center
well then you would be thinking about it
too generally right the knight is
undefended
and not only is it undefended his king
is still in the center so the knight is
a
uh is a magnet for all of these tactics
that involve explaining an undefeated
piece does that make sense so just
because a piece is in the center doesn't
mean it's good
it would become good if black plays d5
and that is why
we don't force the knight out of e4 on
our own volition instead we control
um and prevent a move that could secure
and anchor that knight to the center
queen b3 b5 bishop f7 and rookie one so
instead of ricky one
the move queen d5 was far more
convincing
attacking the rook whoops sorry that was
unintentional uh attacking the rook tag
in the night
getting the queen outside of this pawn
chain so that the move c4
is completely useless and against
circuit one
we enter sort of the tactical state c4
this is where things get really cool
lots of you asked doesn't this win the
queen
right doesn't this win the queen well it
it does in the strict sense right
semantically speaking because he can't
take the bishop he's pinned
but after king f7 who can explain to me
what the problem is
why aren't we just winning the queen
you lose yours your queen is also
hanging that is tunnel vision welcome to
tunnel vision city
we are going to be tackling tunnel
vision 24 7 365 days a year
tunnel vision is when you get fixated on
one particular
aspect or element of the position
element of the position and you ignore
others
and that is one of the most common
problems at various
various gradations of it afflict not
only beginners but but grandmasters as
well
um it's it's it's it's less a particular
weakness than a set of
of mistakes under one umbrella is how i
would call it
uh so for that reason we play bishop
takes c4 then again if we play bishop g5
he goes king f7
so we take the knight and king f6 is the
big mistake
he should have played king f7 the reason
he didn't play it i think
um is is because he was afraid of queen
take c4 check
but what move does black have here what
nasty little move does black have here
i'm going to ask you guys two questions
in succession d5 is correct
four does white lose the rook and if not
can you propose a way that white can
salvage the rook here
so there's a couple of fro no there is a
way to salvage there's
there is many ways to salvage the rook
one is to
when you are in a fork what kinds of
things do you look for to get out of the
fork like what
let's think about it generally a couple
of things
first thing you can do is move one of
the pieces away with check that is the
most robust way
of dealing with the fork well apart from
taking the piece that's delivering the
fork which is not possible here
so you can move the rook away with check
and then move the queen and take the
pawn for good
you could also move one of the pieces
and use tactics
to disallow taking the other piece the
queen b3
that would keep the pod pinned or you
could do an
est equal or stronger threat queen takes
c4 would
be an example of that essentially that
means you are posing
or using an equal or stronger threat to
defend against the initial threat
and the equal or stronger threat is the
fact that you would win the queen
so you can actually do more than three
you can do even more than that
but those are three examples of ways
that you can deal with forks that's what
tactics is
and the more you expose yourself to
tactics and
to these kinds of concepts the better
you become the more fluent you become in
this particular language
and this is high-level stuff tactics
are very hard there's many aspects
to to mastering tactical thinking one of
which is just solving
thousands and thousands of exercises to
train your pattern recognition
the best one would probably hard for me
to say rook out for check probably is
the safest
okay uh so instead my opponent walked
into this
tactic but really his decisive mistake
was not to play d5 here
and had he played d5 here i would have
done
much the same thing as before you could
play queen takes d4
rocket fortune i would probably go queen
takes d4 i think the best move
i mean the best move is probably just to
go rook f4 and the queen takes d4 and if
you
count the material white is up two pawns
and his king is in shambles so we're
still winning here
um okay and you can see how complicated
chess becomes when you've got king on f6
and hanging queen
this is not imaginary you know this is
actual complexity and
it's stuff that we will deal with
together and i hope to arm you with some
of the tools
that you can use to wade through some of
this sort of anarchy on the board
um so questions does this does that make
sense once he gives up his screen the
game is over
and by the way the last thing i was
going to say is the move queen f7 is
actually the fastest mate here
technically speaking
and checkmate with a pawn h3
um and that would be the fastest name we
did queen d5 check and queen g5
technically black and for long in the
game one more move with 95.
now you might look at this and say how
did you
know to look for queen f7
right and as i said earlier there are so
many resources now
where you could just go to puzzles click
on
mate in one you can literally filter
puzzles by made in one
and you solve 50 of them do that for a
week and imagine how much better you're
going to become at recognizing these
patterns
right so a lot of the time that people i
think get confused
about about training right about
what they need to do to get to the next
level the the answer is just to
to solve right and the rest is just
going to come because i think the
misconception people think well i don't
know a key fact
or a key way of thinking that it's
preventing me from getting to the next
level that's why i'm wondering
often the reason isn't that you don't
know something it's that you
don't know how to apply it and you just
got to give yourself more practice okay
i'm not saying that's always the case
that's one thing that you can
sort of advise all right